one of the core ideas i aim to promote
on the bioneer is that we can
and should train every aspect of our
performance and health
losing weight improving cardio or
lifting heavy weights and constrained
movement patterns
should not constitute a comprehensive
fitness program
but for me the biggest omission is brain
training why work
so hard to improve your body and not pay
any attention to brain function
in the digital economy skills like the
ability to focus to manipulate data and
even to make the right impression on
someone
all play a huge role in determining
success and as we'll see here it's also
a very important differentiating factor
when it comes to athletic performance as
well
the main issue brain training also
called cognitive training
is a somewhat controversial topic we now
know that due to brain plasticity
the brain's ability to grow and change
shape in response to environmental
pressures
it is at least somewhat possible to
train the brain
it's no surprise then to learn that
countless apps services and programs
have sprung up to try and capitalize on
this opportunity
usually such packages extrapolate wildly
from the scientific evidence
and charge a lot of cash for results
that they can't guarantee to deliver
less insidious are helpful suggestions
such as using dual
n-back to improve working memory or
exercising to enhance
general cognitive performance there are
plenty of studies supporting the notion
that dual end back training
for example can work wonders for your
working memory and that physical fitness
directly benefits memory mood and focus
but even then there are questions to
what extent can you expect your memory
to noticeably improve if you start
running
how much running do you need to do is
there an upper limit as to how much
benefit you can get
more troubling do exercises like dual
n-back improve working memory across the
board
do they have near transfer to use the
technical lingo for similar tasks
or do they only improve working memory
for that task and others like it
how can you tell if a task truly has
improved useful brain function
beyond the kind that can be tested in a
controlled setting for example
the dual n-back test is a challenge that
involves holding on to data and
manipulating it
using working memory the goal is to look
out for repeats in the series of numbers
but where the conditions become
increasingly complex one study published
in the journal of cognitive enhancement
found this could indeed effectively
improve working memory
to determine this effect the study used
a number of strategies these included a
test of general fluid intelligence and
iq test
to which there was no measured benefit
an object n-back test
the same thing but using real-world
objects for which there was a clear
benefit
and a task switching test for which
there was a less pronounced benefit
the study also used an eeg to measure
brain activity
so if we break this down we see that
dual mbac was unable to increase iq
scores which arrive with their own
issues to begin with
and the object n-back test is really
just the same test using slightly
different stimuli
task switching is a more interesting
result showing that this could improve
serial tasking in the workplace
thereby allowing a person to switch from
one activity to another more effectively
with a less of a cost of productivity
but even then this is measured using a
very artificial test that really doesn't
represent anything we do in real life
and keep in mind in order for this type
of training to be useful it must also be
more beneficial than real world
activities
like chess or practicing math otherwise
why not simply perform those much more
interesting activities instead
what i find really interesting about
this is that there are some very clear
parallels to functional training
we can improve our working memory but if
the setting is highly artificial we
might find it doesn't hold up in a real
world setting
this is especially true seeing as
working memory is in all likelihood
multimodal
we tend to talk about working memory in
terms of seven plus or minus two that is
to say
a person can hold on to five to nine
digits whilst trying to find a pen to
write down a phone number
but working memory is also responsible
for a football player's ability to
remember the relative positions
of all their teammates on the field
while they run in the other direction
can we really describe this as seven
plus or minus two we've not experienced
the world in discrete packages of
accurate data
rather we clutch onto disparate bits of
information and then use these to form
an impressionistic idea of the world
around us
a patchwork creation that is useful
enough rather than perfectly accurate
and so it should come as no surprise
that working memory works best in this
manner
this makes a lot of sense in the context
of neuroscientists daniel wolpert's
belief that the brain evolved
for movement or as i like to think of it
to communicate with the environment
this is also of course why we have
bodies as walpert described in his
excellent ted talk we really are
bayesian inference machines we make
predictions based on large amounts of
imperfect data
coming in from our senses and this also
provides another explanation as to why
we see activation in the cerebellum
a brain region primarily responsible for
handling proprioception and body sense
when engaging in abstract cognitive
tasks
so how might we practically train
working memory then often the best place
to look when it comes to cutting-edge
training
is the world of athletics this is where
a lot of money is spent trying to
optimize human performance
and cognitive training makes a lot of
sense for athletes after all the outcome
of a game or match is seldom predicated
on the objective strength speed or
endurance of the athletes in question
here there is an absolutely tiny amount
of difference between any two candidates
instead what's more important is the way
the players perform on the day which
comes down to the decisions they make
their ability to stay focused under
pressure and much more
so for an example how might an athlete
train their working memory in order to
make better decisions in the heat of a
contest
one study found that using the simon
task an activity that requires
participants to make different physical
responses to different stimuli
could help improve a lacrosse player's
ability to target the right part of a
goal quickly
another study looked at the use of 3d
multiple object tracking tasks
to successfully improve the decision
making of football players
this is one of the first studies to show
useful transfer effects between a
non-contextual cognitive training
and an actual sporting event but again
notice it's still in 3d space it's still
much more
sensory rich than a dual mbac test other
studies have also shown that athletes
have a generally higher proficiency
when it comes to performance in these
tasks so while using 3d object tasks
might be of some use to athletes it's
also true that sports themselves are a
fantastic form of brain training that
the rest of us could benefit from
likewise playing computer games might
have some benefit for real-world
decision-making
one study found that 3d action games
could improve decision-making speed
with no loss in accuracy this should
come as no surprise as computer games
require heated decisions
based on large amounts of information
all immersed in a 3d space
that said it's worth noting this study
was funded by the entertainment software
association
demonstrating another issue with
research and cognitive training that
there's often a lot of vested interests
involved
i personally believe that there's a huge
amount of potential benefit for playing
computer games at a high level
especially when they make the jump to
virtual reality for a truly
multi-sensory context
i also believe that brain training games
should learn a thing or two from 3d
titles like devil may cry or overwatch
and the military clearly agrees as
they've been using esports to recruit
drone pilots and fill other roles
for some time now whatever the case many
sports coaches are now selling cognitive
training
as part of their programs these
protocols often involve running between
numbered cones or carrying out complex
sequences of events
and responding to commands seeing this
type of training immerses the athlete in
physical movement
while asking them to perform mental
tasks there's a fairly high chance that
it could be beneficial
but of course most football players not
albert einstein why don't we see more
nobel prize winning athletes the answer
may be related to the more modular
descriptions of the brain
that's to say that this is a different
type of intelligence and one that has
little relation to the kind of quick
decision making and reflexes required by
most sports
that's not to say i subscribe to a
theory of multiple intelligence where
each works entirely independently of the
other
but there's no denying that you can
train for specific skills and abilities
just as someone who goes on lots of long
runs is training their body
but not their strength specifically so
we can learn to predict the movements of
players on a pitch
benefiting the brain without that
transferring over to abstract reasoning
and creative problem solving but we can
take the lessons we've learned from
looking at this type of training
and apply it to other areas areas like
memory creativity
focus problem solving emotional
intelligence
self-monitoring emotional hardness and
so forth
so here we want to make the training
again as multi-sensory as possible and
as close to the specific skills and
abilities
we want to benefit we can see an example
of this used by navy seals
the hooded box drill this is a
particularly intense mental exercise
that involves placing participants in a
hood that blocks their sight and hearing
then pulling the hood off in an
unexpected combat situation
this is intended to not only desensitize
them to fear and shock
but also to train rapid decision making
and orientation
this is a step above most things we
consider brain training but it's not
impossible to replicate with
say virtual reality the more
multi-centering grounded the activity
the greater the likelihood of seeing
real transfer to other skills and
situations
for most of us this usually means taking
up new hobbies and activities that
already exist
playing musical instruments programming
meditation chess
rapping reading aloud these all have
immense benefits exercise
keep in mind that the activities you
engage in every single day such as your
career
are likely to have the biggest impact on
your brain function and may even alter
aspects of your personality
my recommendation would be to take up a
few of these highly cognitively
demanding activities
picking the ones that best align with
your own goals strengths and weaknesses
and of course there are countless other
aspects of brain training that work in
entirely different ways
that don't strengthen particular areas
or networks of the brain
for example the very process of learning
new skills will increase plasticity
thus helping you to learn every other
new skill then there's nutrition
or how about the simple fact that you
can drive more energy to your brain
using cardio
and other methods to improve metabolic
rate and cardiovascular health
there are endless ways to improve brain
function and i have a hunch this is
going to be a massive topic in the
coming
decades the best thing we can do right
now is to get a head start
[Music]
so if you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around that helps
me out immensely
i'd love to know what you think about
cognitive training what methods you've
used for yourself
to enhance your gray matter if you like
the idea of training that goes beyond
the usual small selection of exercises
to build every aspect of human
performance then you may enjoy my ebook
and training program
super functional training that program
actually combines both physical and
cognitive training
in a single routine that anyone can
follow and provides a lot more
information to sink your teeth into
there's a link to that in the
description down below there's a
discount on right now whilst many of us
are in lockdown
either way thank you so much for
watching this one subscribe if you want
to see more like it
and i'll catch you next time thanks a
ton
and bye for now